today's story comes from a former NBA
player NBA champion Steven Jackson you
might have seen him on ESPN has a show
with Matt Barnes really good Instagram
life and this caught my attention so I
clipped it I want to show it to you guys
me and her together we've been together
for like a year too but I proposed to
her and during that time you know we
plan to get married in Houston I take
care a lot of people
I'm never letting one one with control
of all the hard work I've done in my
life
none of these mothers in the gym with me
right so in fact I always saw myself who
ever married to they signing the prenup
off top I'm not it's not even a second
guess so man I had to talk about it so
it's we get the prenup back at least
three four months before the wedding
right I gave it to her granted when I
give it to her she shouldn't be
surprised by because me and her sat down
and agreed upon the prenup
a month past like two months photo and
I'm like yo look we need to get that
prenup sign so we can go and you know
send it in and get it you know get all
that taken care of so when we get down
at Houston when you gotta worry about it
I tell them that like two or three times
it's a month ago that was two months
before the win
it's the month before the wedding she's
like I'm assigning I'm assigned I'm
assigning I'm assigned I'm assigned I'm
a son I'm like cool you can sign but
look during that time we making
arrangements for the wedding right cuz
you know you still got a plan so you
know I love her and I'm gonna keep
really I was in love with her and we was
building a family so I'm like okay cool
hang on make a little big deal III went
we're planning a wedding I didn't stop I
kept planning the wedding
so as we planned it for the wedding she
from New York I'm from Texas I'm from
Port Arthur which is an hour from
Houston where we get married I want my
pastor to do it he right there
there to save us some money got a duck
she is adamant about this certain pastor
doing the thing right some other girl
brought the pastor named - let's hit
this say there's a pastor she's never
seen so I'm like cool is this her win I
ain't got no problem keep in mind
remember this
answer right I spoke by phone the
thousand on the wedding yeah by faux
honey k right now we had two weeks
before the wind everything plan we ready
to go I'm like look bruh why I gotta
keep asking you about this prenup but it
ain't like you don't know what's on it
like what motives this is what I told
her what's you up to what motives you
own I ain't know nothing I just say had
time to sign up planning a where Knox
I'm like man listen man how you gonna do
a sign this the date of the wind wake up
that morning we I'm getting dressed in
the back of my mind you know some I'm
all think about this damn prenup right
that's all I'm thinking about this while
this why Stephon Marbury might giving my
brothers I for life we in the back we
walk to the back room and the the priest
come in had the preacher come in with it
with this with this other with his
assistant I guess and then my nanny come
back in there with a widow whether like
us would spook look on her face like she
still like she she pulled me to the side
and she like she still ain't signed it
Oh ain't no I ain't getting married
stuff like she signed a prenup what the
what weave in here for my kids are I
ain't doing it the preacher steps up
he's like holo holo holo holo hold on he
say now now hold on don't know I know
you love this girl
don't make a drastic decision I think
you should just let God handle priest
just had some flashbacks to his
childhood give me a minute guys he was
not having none of that he was really
upset by that damn while like you knew
what it was in that clip right you knew
what was in that clip right right
you stand there let me play you a little
clip since won't be fun
you knew damn well I was how I was about
to react when I was about to react when
he said that damn day you know damn well
what the he was doing can't stands you
let God handle it man God is gonna
handle this money you gonna lose what
[Music]
bro go ahead let it out man I'm here for
you oh man Oh
that is got to uh need to use your words
I can't even put it in lose your words
you always tell me that you made you
make that do nothing did that take down
ability exactly with the exactly
accountability you know what you did oh
man yeah it's just guarding the lid and
no sign the prenup has to be the dummy
I've ever heard
why does it bother you so much
yo man is the lack of logic maybe hmm
it made sense up to now if we're talking
about you let God handle it now why did
you bring up you know in the first place
he plays for the NBA right he's a pastor
who told him like God handled I
understand that I roll my eyes whatever
the pastor it's not his money it's not
his wedding go prays right right right
you tell me you let God handle it yeah
but win win the fan and I ain't got
nothing else we're not gonna call those
brothers right and I mean obviously
God's there but you don't throw a leave
everything to God right it's like you
don't just leave your front door wide
open and you're safe wide open and say
let God handle it there's nothing wrong
with taking precautions and still
believing in a higher power when people
say stuff like this to me it's very
dangerous because it's just telling
people you don't have to worry about it
God will take care of it whatever
happens happens no you should still
protect gosh it's if you do something
stupid you can't say let God handle it
No
yeah let me drink and drive let God
handle it it doesn't work like that you
have to do something but it's her pastor
don't forget that so I say huh I think
you should just let God happen to me as
the pastor I don't believe in prenups
nah know why she was fighting for you
you don't believe in prenups not all
makes sense I ain't getting married damn
what you believe in I put everything in
God's hand and God is telling me to put
the pen in her hand and make us sign his
goddamn prenup that's what God said to
me so God telling me you two different
things
as that's going on Steph Marbury grows
crazy hell nah no we ain't doing it no
it ain't going on step go crazy
Mike baby walks are you serious Steve
out of here everybody no no no no no bro
this preacher has the nerve to sit there
for about five or ten minutes and try to
convince me that God so that he don't
believe in prenups so I shouldn't
believe in them listen for weighing in
the same tax bracket first of all okay
listen girls
if you're not in the same tax bracket
prenup
man if you ain't in the same tax bracket
just here's what I say you have to I do
a prenup if you made that wealth before
y'all got together or you made a
substantial amount of it prenup if you
guys have started from the bottom
together and worked your way up which i
think is your situation yeah that's a
different story
absolutely but you're not allowed to
come in after I've already built the
Empire and think you deserve half you
bet you've been in the NBA play shot
then you meet her because you were
baller and after that she's gonna join
in on the ride and you're gonna be like
I think half yours he said it himself
you wasn't at the gym pushing the white
wedding off when everybody something I
was going on we all get back to my room
I break down crying duh honest to god
truth I can't lie cuz I was hurt cuz I
was ready to I wanted to marry her
brother this is the honest-to-god truth
I break down crying dollar by the good
20-30 minutes
Mike Bibby my walk up to me though and
he's bringing tears to my eyes today she
walk up to me she grab her hand
my baby's mom wipe the snot and all this
from my face everything from my face and
she picked my chin up and she said you
became a man today [ __ ] that's a good
story
mother's I get where that comes from
you've had to make a very difficult
decision but it was the right
is good yeah as I'm wiping my stairs and
stuff off you know I'm saying you ready
to go downstairs a party huh somebody
from her side comes to my room and say
hey Steve hold on just calm down she
want to talk to you all right I go talk
to her
so look I get in the room she's still in
her wedding dress and she crying right
so soon as I walk in the room she hard
down crying I'll sign it out sign it go
to the dog save them whatever I'll sign
it out started listen I was born at
night but not last night born at night
but not last night and now this
relationship about to go night-night
one thing I know
anytime somebody signs anything where
they cry or the any type of stress or
any really emotional or something like
that that can get thrown out that's a
very good point if you sign something
under duress we can get thrown out so
anyone who is under emotional stress and
kind of physical stress that's whatever
if they sign something yeah it's not a
valid contract it can be voided yeah
wise man yeah well he's learned you
making if you make it 20 30 million 40
men you better learn about it so even
that is that he's in either NBA player
he's been around other stories as well
sure other mother got played anything
stuff any scene stuff so bad oh you know
remember I told you stuff was turnt up
I'm telling my dog this [ __ ] stuff on
my Barry's crazy dog soon as we get to
downstairs he our it in a DJ booth as
people walk in guess was the first song
they played she gives me money
we're nominee yeah she's a trifling
friend indeed oh yeah she's a gold
digger way over town there's good to me
oh you know I'm gonna keep all 1,000
child after we deliver her party at the
hotel me and all my parties get ready to
go out that night two of her main
squeezes that was there with her was
with us that night
and I'm gonna keep it funky I dialed one
of them one of her best friends when a
[ __ ] has to look left before he gives
you that you know it's um so what are
your thoughts I mean I'm not really
about like the last part was like yeah
back her friend that night we put four
hundred thousand dollars into the
wedding I understand that I'm your best
friend if you [ __ ] with my prenup and
did all this stuff I'm not but I'm
somebody I'm getting my bag your bag is
gonna turn into a bang this nights gonna
be consummated I just hope it's with you
four hundred thousand dollars and you
played me another day of this wouldn't
know you
she was trifling yes who's right here's
my thing ladies ladies if you don't want
to sign a prenup I can understand all
right
don't speak but what you shouldn't do is
agree to the prenup like she did and try
to spring like some kind of surprise
attack on the day of the wedding that
was her mistake she was manipulated she
agreed to the prenup and on the day of
she tried to throw some past random no
you're in the wrong for that it's not
some trick or treat it's not Halloween
try to shake yeah don't try to you know
don't try to do anything funny yeah
and if you're gonna get married to
somebody who's filthy rich I don't think
you should have the right to their money
either but guys you should sign a prenup
if you don't whatever happens to you
happens to you you know you should watch
some girls some girls what they're only
about what thing that thing that thing I
paint that paper think that paper thing
okay so I agree with that
I feel the same way if I was to make a
lot of money and I met someone
afterwards you're not getting access to
that money that's me though what do you
think yeah absolutely
I'm not a situation no but still you've
been from the girl started from the
bottom now you're here together though
even then like get married she came out
if it would be done I would walk away
hmm pretty David
what should it sign a prenup know if
things wouldn't work out I was just walk
away I'm gonna take her money
it's not no no no Craig David yeah
I'm mopping away yeah yeah that's a good
song I heard this boy and I really want
to share it with you guys cuz I thought
it was a good story of someone being
smart with their money and making the
right choice you know unfortunately had
to happen on the wedding day and so much
money was lost there but he saved way
more money in the long run with more
choice now there's more to this video if
you actually go look it up or stephen
jackson if you look it up he's how
stories about how she tried to take
advantage of him
after they were separated to child
support and some weird stuff that she
did what i just want to bring this up to
say guys be smart about your money be
smart about your finances ladies as well
if you're the one who's making way more
they're gonna come for you too all right
not every guys preach not every guy's
not gonna ask for his money yeah ask
Kevin Federline Oh ain't you gettin paid
you can't pay pay there you go so super
babe just something to think about yeah
don't forget to subscribe to the patreon
and wiser youtube podcast we have on all
the platforms that's right have a brief
podcast
[Music]